director Matt Reeves is the Batman may
not have Ben Affleck rocking the cape
and cowl anymore but what it does
apparently have our two main villains
plucks straight from the Batman Canon
the second of which may have just been
revealed a casting breakdown for the
Batman obtained by we got this covered
through undisclosed sources reportedly
details that the secondary baddie in the
film is a character currently being
billed as the brain there's a villain
who goes by that name in the DC Universe
a mad scientist best known for serving
as a member of the Brotherhood of Evil
joining the secret society of super
villains and battling against the band
of crime-fighting misfits known as the
Doom Patrol it would be an interesting
choice for a central antagonist in a
more noir driven detective version of
Batman especially considering the brain
and Batman aren't exactly arch enemies
of course it's entirely possible that
the brain isn't the secondary villain in
the forthcoming film after all but
simply a code for a different
supervillain set the battle Batman
according to week out this cupboards
Intel the brain is actually code for a
far more predominant DC Comics villain
the Riddler as abbott batman readers
will know the brain could here be a
reference to the fact that the Riddler
is Batman's most intelligent arch
villain otherwise known as Edward nygma
The Riddler possesses genius level
smarts and rebels and crafting dastardly
plots that involve complex riddles traps
and puzzles showy / elaborate and
weirdly passionate about the crimes he
commits the Riddler has long existed as
one of Batman's greatest and most
notorious adversaries what squeals
louder than a cop read it cut read what
makes the Riddler's presence in the
reves helmed flick even more plausible
is that the primary bad guy of the
Batman is reported to be the penguin
this Gotham City mobster has a flair for
the dramatic and a penchant for all
things avian a team-up between the two
villains wouldn't be too out of the
ordinary either since the penguin has
frequently partnered with the Riddler
both on screen and off while the Fox
television series Gotham has depicted
both the Riddler and the penguin
throughout the show's run
neither villain has appeared on the big
screen since the 1990s Tim Burton's
Batman Returns featured Danny DeVito as
the penguin while Joel Schumacher's 1995
feature Batman Forever saw Jim Carrey
given over-the-top performance as the
Riddler some might argue that Carrey and
DeVito were perfect and maybe even
irreplaceable in their roles but it's
been over 25 years since the release of
Batman Returns and Batman Forever and
the Riddler and the penguin are long
overdue for a silver screen facelift
rivas movie could be the perfect
platform to do just that obviously it
goes without saying that this is all
guesswork for now no one directly
involved with a Batman has confirmed
that the Riddler will be part of the
story and nobody has cooperated the talk
that the penguin will appear either
nonetheless this rumor does seem just
about plausible enough to be true and it
can only help that the Riddler has
already found his roots in the DC
extended universe thanks to a sneaky
little easter egg in Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice until someone finally
steps up and confirms the Batman's lead
villains however fans are just going to
have to count down the days until the
film releases
June 25th 2021 of course if that gets
too boring they could always pass the
time by fan casting the Riddler
our money's on DiCaprio check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]